Russia's giving the angle a serious case
of deja vu after it's now Banning an
anti-war candidate from challenging
Putin the Electoral commission voting
unanimously to reject an independent
candidate's candidacy just 3 days after
her application citing 100 mistakes on
her forms because that's what happens in
autocracies that's what happens in
dictatorships in fact the Electoral
Commission in Russia acknowledged that
29 people have filed to run for the
Russian presidency but just one
candidate is actually able to register I
wonder who it is that's right Putin
meanwhile here in the United States in
Colorado in a 4 to3 ruling justices
declared Donald J Trump ineligible for
the ballot citing section three of the
14th Amendment now to be clear this is
an 1868 amendment that was passed in the
wake of the Civil War it's been used
only a handful of times to go after
Confederates but bring in Donald J Trump
and let's delegitimize him from the
bench with a novel and bogus legal
Theory the ruling sure to be appealed to
the Supreme Court but is it yet another
attempt at election interference first
it was Russian collusion then two
impeachments then the so-called
unverified Hunter laptop oh wait they
verified that one and then you got the
four indictments and now
disqualification from the ballot sensing
a pattern I certainly am and if you
think you could just write Donald J
Trump well think again the Colorado
decision reads the secretary may not
list president Trump's name on the 2024
presidential primary ballot nor may she
count any Rin votes cast for him that
sounds like Russia not the United States
of America joining us now is former
deputy independent Council and Fox News
contributor Saul weisenberg Saul I I
mean you can't even write in the guy's
name I what's going on here in the
Supreme Court what do you think is is a
trajectory to hopefully overturning
this oh I think the Supreme Court is
going to take the case and uh I think
they're going to reverse the Colorado
Supreme Court fairly
quickly fairly quickly so do you think
you know history serves you have all of
these five four decisions very narrow do
you think we could see a nine o reversal
some of those justices move
over I I would certainly like to see
that Kayla you know they're going to
have to look at a lot of things this
term that relate to president Trump
they're going to have I think they're
going to take a look at presidential
immunity in the context of criminal
prosecutions uh I think they may take a
look at the gag order and I think it's
very important that they try to decide
this uh with as much unanimity as they
can and I really think this will not be
a particularly close decision the this
section of the 14th amendment that the
Colorado Supreme Court utiliz the
majority is simply not self-executing in
my view and that was a position of the
then Chief Justice of the United States
salmon Chase in 1869 less than one year
after the 14th amendment was ratified I
don't see this as much so much as an
issue of election interference though it
is as another example of trump
derangement syndrome this time in the
Judiciary and and I I point out I say
this not as a poltical iCal supporter of
President Trump I've never politically
supported president Trump but these
efforts are very very disturbing and
they're very
anti-democratic and you know I would
love to know your theory on this but
I've heard other legal analysts say and
and you know this you know I've went to
law school textualism you look at
history you look at president and a lot
of folks say there's a reason the
president isn't listed in this section
they list all these other office holders
but they don't list the president and
you read that with intent attention by
Design our Founders thought about each
and every single word so do you think
this section three of the 14th Amendment
even applies to a former
president you know that's very much
disputed I think they're good arguments
on both sides it's certainly not clear
to me that it does apply to the
president and then if it's not clear as
you know if the text isn't clear then
you get to go to history and structure
and things like that so some of these
questions are close on this issue of
what the Clause means but to me the
critical the critical thing which was uh
discussed in one of the descents I
believe it was Justice santor or Sam
door who focused on enry Griffin and the
fact that this is not self-executing
what that means is Congress must put
teeth into this section of the 14th
Amendment Congress must say here is how
we are going to enforce this
disqualification Clause now now they did
that uh they passed the criminal law
it's still on the books uh 18 USC
2383 Jack Smith did not indict president
former president Trump for that so
that's one critical thing it's not a
self-executing portion of the 14th
Amendment and two you have to provide
due process uh you have to provide due
process to somebody that you're going to
take off the ballot and the process
provided here was an absolute joke
president Trump's people didn't have the
right to subpoena documents they didn't
have the right to subpoena Witnesses uh
there was not a fair trial in any sense
of the word
here no no due process not
self-executing fascinating analysis Saul
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else